all right so here is a research paper published
by NASA and it credits T. H. Skopinski and
Katherine Johnson it was written at the Langley
research center and was written in September
1960. That's a year before Alan Shepard would
become the first American in space and before John
Glenn would become the first American to orbit the
earth. The legacy of people like Katherine Johnson
has helped to bring a lot of attention to the
work done at NASA around this time, calculating
how to put people up in space and how to bring
them back down safely. The movie Hidden Figures
especially highlighted the role of human computers
in that work but until now I never really knew
what that work would have looked like. I knew that
Katherine Johnson's work as shown in the movie
had something to do with orbital mechanics or
analytic geometry but I was curious to know what
the actual calculations and equations were so
that's why I went looking through the archives
to find the actual documents. This is the first
report that officially includes Katherine's name
on the cover page but it's not the first report
she worked on it's called the determination of
azimuth angle at burnout for placing a satellite
over a selected earth position. Let's go through
some of the terms. The azimuth angle is measured
from north and is the angle that you're pointing
when you launch a rocket, often and is limited by
safety we don't really want to launch rockets over
populated areas or over houses and so if you're
launching you often want to have your azimuth
angle such that you're going to launch out over
the ocean and burnout refers to the shut off of
the rocket engine so after the burnout point the
orbital parameters are essentially locked in and
we can then just work with newton's laws and other
equations to find out where it's going to be.
Because the azimuth angle at launch will affect
where the satellite is going to end up after a
certain number of orbits, this paper is trying to
find out what launch azimuth angle you would need
in order to end up at a selected earth position
after a set number of orbits so say you want your
astronaut to splash down in a certain region
on earth so that you can go and retrieve them
well the math in this paper is working out
what you would need to do at launch and able to
ensure that. They start by listing out a bunch of
symbols, we have things like the semi-major axis
and the eccentricity relating to the shape of
the elliptical orbit and we have the inclination
angle of the orbital plane and some of the
parameters make reference to the perigee location
which is the point when the satellite is closest
to the center of the earth. It says here that if
we know the initial conditions of speed, radial
distance and elevation angle at burnout those
will all determine the orbital characteristics
of a satellite. So going on to work out a way to
relate all of these parameters they start with a
bit of elementary orbital mechanics for which they
reference An Introduction to Celestial Mechanics
published in 1914. These are all derivations
working towards that ultimate relationship between
the azimuth angle and the longitude and latitude
that we wish to land at. These calculations were
done by hand likely by Katherine Johnson herself
but then it says here that the results for both
cases are then compared with the results obtained
by a method of a three degree of freedom
calculation performed on an IBM 704 electronic
data processing machine. This would be around the
time that NASA got its very first computers, its
IBM machines which would have been huge and taken
up an entire room and very difficult to use. They
go on to present two example orbit calculations,
one for a satellite that is launched westward and
one for satellite launched eastward just to show
that this method is not limited by the direction
of launch. This page here is a summary of all of
the equations that were derived and that will be
useful in the calculation and it actually involves
a bit of an iterative procedure because we don't
initially know anything about the orbital angle
or the time it takes to get to a certain position
we just have this first approximation for the
time it's taken to get to a selected point we can
feed that approximation into another equation and
that value into another until we start to see some
convergence in the values we're getting for the
angle after we're happy with this much we can then
finally feed the parameters into an equation to
find the azimuth angle and the inclination angle
telling us what we need to launch the satellite.
There's also a mention of oblateness effects
because the earth is not perfectly spherical and
the oblateness is taken into account with small
modifications to the latitude and longitude values
after the first iteration. And these are the exact
equations here that Katherine Johnson would
have been calculating in her role as a computer
but for this paper she also had a lot to
do with deriving them in the first place.
In 1960 no woman at NASA had ever had her name
included on a report. Katherine Johnson worked
on this report with Ted Skopinski and their
supervisor encouraged Skopinski to finish the
report and just put his name on it before going
away on a trip to Houston but Ted said "Katherine
should be the one to finish it she's done most
of the work anyway" and so it became the first of
26 reports to include Katherine's name. If you
take a look at these photos you might notice these
calculator-looking devices on people's desks
and these were mechanical calculating aids.
Here is a video from youtube of a restored one
showing the kind of process that it uses. There's
no electronics in one of these but they can do
arithmetic like addition and subtraction quite
easily and through a bit more of a convoluted
process can also do multiplication and division
and even find things like square root that
is all done through a series of amazing and
intricate mechanical movements. Katherine likely
had access to one of these to help her step
through the calculations and something else that
she might have had would have been a log table.
Working out big tables of logarithms and
also trigonometry values was something that
motivated us inventing computers in the first
place to make calculating these tables easier and
ensure that there are less mistakes.
Engineers around this time would have
also used the slide rule but i'm thinking
that here these calculations need to be done
to really a high degree of accuracy maybe four or
five decimal places at least and so a slide rule
might not be able to offer that kind of precision
but a log table especially one made for engineers
can go right up to five six or seven significant
figures. For the first example the eastward launch
we have a given launch position and also a
selected reentry position and we're going to do
three orbits. These are the values that Katherine
worked out using those equations on the previous
page and using her first approximation. We can do
a little recreation of this using the log table,
taking the first equation and the values
we've been given which fills out to this,
we can do the subtraction by hand although the
division and the multiplication is a bit harder.
In the grand scheme of things though this equation
is pretty short and simple so maybe she wouldn't
have needed to use log tables for this but we'll
use them for the sake of illustration. A quick
reminder about logarithms, if you have a thousand
that could be rewritten as 10 to the power of 3
so the log in base 10 of a thousand is three.
The log of a hundred is two and the log of ten
is one. For a log of base ten it is rewriting
your number as ten to the power of something
and that something in the power is your logarithm.
Converting our numbers into logarithms is useful
because instead of dividing two numbers you can
just subtract their logarithms and instead of
multiplying two numbers you can just add their
logarithms. First we want to find the log of
91.585 there are two significant figures before
the decimal point so we do two minus one is one
so our number is going to start with
one point something to find the rest
we go to the table this is a five place log
table and we're looking for nine one five
eight five. The first three digits are here we
come down to nine one five then across to 8.
now the first two digits are missing off of this
value which says 180 and the first two digits are
over here they are 96. so our logarithm is 9 6 1 8
0 but then because we had nine one five eight five
we also need to add a two point five giving us
nine six one eight two five doing the same thing
for our other numbers we end up with the three
logarithms that we want. We want to add the logs
of these two values since they're multiplied
and subtract this one, that gives us 0.88610
but we're not at an answer we're in a strange
realm of logarithms and to get back to our final
answer we need to take the anti-log of it there's
a table for that too we are looking for 0.88610
That will be 7 6 9 1 plus 2 so 7 6 9 3. Our
decimal point will be placed between the 7
and the 6 to give us exactly the same answer
that Katherine Johnson has recorded down here
take 7.693 and feed it into here with our
other known values and you'll get 32.162
take the cosine of that multiply it by the cosines
of the latitudes plus the sines of the latitudes
take the inverse cosine of this whole thing
and then add on the angle at burnout and you
should get 51.89 and taking the sines,
cosines or inverse cosines can be done
by looking it up in the table. For example the
sine of phi 2 our latitude 34 degrees would be
34 degrees point 0, the sine is 0.5591.
From these four expressions you'll get your
first approximations of these four values.
We are given a reference value of t of theta
one so you can use that and the new value
you've worked out for t theta 2 e to go back
and calculate a new value of this parameter.
Feed that into these equations again
and you'll get your second iteration
but also for that use new values for your latitude
and your longitude that are corrected for the
oblateness of the earth. Doing that whole process
four times gives you this table of iterations.
Because we've reached a point where we've
got some kind of convergence to a value here
we can take these values and use them with our
last two equations to work out the azimuth angle
and the inclination angle. Going back to compare
our results with that of the new IBM computer
it says that using the azimuth angle calculated by
the method of this paper an orbit was calculated
by the computer for an oblate rotating earth and
it's the trace of that resulting orbit that is
presented in figure 5a, so this is actually what
the computer has given us for what the orbit will
look like. Doing it by hand like in this paper
indicates that the selected position would be
reached in 281.316 minutes but the computer data
indicates that at the same time the satellite
would be 18.6 nautical miles west of the desired
position and wouldn't reach the desired position
until 281.398 minutes which is just a little
bit later so this agreement is considered good.
Now we can do these things pretty much instantly,
here's some code on mathematica which generates a
graphic where you can just move the slider and
see how moving the azimuth angle will change
the location of the satellite after however
many orbits you like. When the big IBM computer
was first used to calculate the trajectory of a
flight, astronaut John Glenn actually asked if
Katherine Johnson could verify the calculations
so that he could feel confident going up.
She reproduced some of the computer's calculations
by hand to make sure it was doing the right thing.
In the hidden figures movie there's also a scene
where the character who plays Katherine johnson
is talking about Euler's method she says that they
can use Euler's method to solve a problem about
going from an elliptical orbit to a parabolic one
she runs off to the side and finds a book that she
opens up to learn about the topic and from that
tiny screen grab i did manage to find out which
book that was it's this one The Mathematics of
Physics and Chemistry by Margenau and Murphy.
And here we can find the same page it's about the
modified Euler method and this is about taking
small iterative steps to solve a differential
equation we didn't have any differential equations
in the paper that we just looked at so this
would have been used for different work entirely,
likely having to do with actually trying to
plot the path of the rocket perhaps using the
rocket equation which is a differential equation
but i think that's enough for this video thank
you for watching and a special shout out
to today's Patreon cat of the day June.